لنحو 13 عاما كان قيصر يعمل في الشرطه
العسكريه بسوريا وظيفته معظم الوقت كانت
التحقيق بمسرح الجريمه التقاط الصور حيث
كان ياخذ صورا لصالح الشرطه توثق النشاطات
الاجراميه المرتكبه لكن مع بدايه الحرب
الاهليه تغير عمله ليصبح التقاط صور للجثث
التي تاتي من مراكز الاحتجاز للاشخاص
الذين قتلوا في السج
واخذوا لمستشفى عسكري ورغم انني اعرف
مكانه الا انه لا يمكن الافصاح عن ذلك
لاسباب عديده هذه الجثث جلبت بالترتيب
الذي تم فيه التقاط الصور واعتقد ان ذلك
لاسباب تعود الى اظهار توثيق للحكومه
والمسؤولين في النظام بان الاوامر نفذت في
حقيقه
الامر
سيد جفري بحسب علمك لمن تعود هذه الجثث من
كان هؤلاء الاشخاص هل كانوا سجناء حرب ام
كانوا معارضين سياسيين هل يعرف قيصر من
هم لا وكان واضحا بانه لم يرى ابدا عمليه
اعدام او
تعذيب اذا كان يصور النتائج
فقط صحيح نحن لسنا على علم بحملهم اي
اشارات تظهر انهم كانوا رجالا في الخدمه
لا يمكننا الذهاب ابعد من ذلك بطبيعه
الحال لان اغلب الجثث لم يغطيها اي شكل من
اشكال اللباس او اي علامه اخرى من شانها
ان تشير الى ما اذا كانوا جنودا ام
لا ماذا حدث للجثث بحسب ما قاله قيصر لكم
ما فهمناه هو انه تم اخذهم من مكان لتصوير
مقابر جماعيه في منطقه ريفيه قريبه حيث
دفنوا
فيها قضيتم قاده في محاكم الامم المتحده
هل يمكنكم اخذ هذه الادله
للمحكمه ماذا ستثبت هذه الادله جرائم ضد
الانسانيه ام جرائم حرب اكثر
خطوره هذه جرائم ضد الانسانيه بالتاكيد
ومن شان هذه الادله دعم تهم بارتكاب جرائم
ضد الانسانيه من دون ادنى
شك لكن لا نملك حق اتخاذ القرار
كل ما يسعنا القيام به هو تقييم الادله
وتحديد ما اذا كانت المحكمه ستقبل لاننا
وصلنا الى استنتاج مفاده ان منشقا عرضها
وهذه الادله مستقله استنادا الى الادله
العلميه ونظرا الى الادله ذاتها واعتقد ان
هذا ينطبق على زملائي ايضا انها ادله
دامغه بكل
تاكيد هب